is back this was a Renault Factory till
last year but like so many Western
companies the French automaker pulled up
Stakes over the Russian invasion of
Ukraine so Russia nationalized the plant
and it now produces the moskovic a brand
from the old Soviet days
some thought everything would collapse
said President Vladimir Putin this month
nothing is falling apart our domestic
manufacturers now have opportunities
hardship was expected to come from
Global sanctions designed to punish
Russia is adopted
the United Nations voted this week once
more overwhelmingly to denounce The
Invasion but just how isolated has the
war left Russia like the U.N vote last
year 141 countries demanded Russia
withdraw from Ukraine only seven
including Russia voted against but there
were also more than 30 abstentions many
African countries plus India and China
those two countries with over 35 percent
of the world's population have not
shunned Russia Russian oil exports to
China soared to 2 million barrels a day
last month and to India 1.4 million
barrels a day a record high whether
selling energy to China and India or
buying military drones from Iran or
artillery shells from North Korea Russia
can still find Partners to help both its
economy and its military
President Putin met with a top Chinese
official this week a message to the
world that Russia has friends China is
building new pipelines to transport
Russian gas from Siberia and Putin is
strengthening relationships with the
so-called Global South you can think of
the use of sanctions as being perhaps
weakening Russia in a very long term but
in terms of altering Behavior right now
no it's not going to have any impact
back at home old Russian Brands like
Kama bicycles are having a Revival
I used to write a comma says Tatiana I
feel positive for our producers most
Russians says one moscow-based pollster
are adapting to a more rustified economy
they don't think about the direct
influence of the sanctions or us we are
we are strong and we can stand
everything the moskovich wasn't very
popular back in the old Soviet days but
in a time of economic sanctions
consumers have no choice but to consider
Russian brands that they once turned
away from Eric Sorensen Global News